c'était génial
il obtient inoubliable franchement
inoubliable
enfin que je possède pas que ça démontre
flottant dans vos têtes mythe et il
offre la fini mais c'est ce serait cette
occasion
l'impression qu'ils se prouvent qu'ils
sont capables de faire des choses ils
sont capables de faire des choses
le grand raid en dix jours là c'est une
aventure extraordinaire
ils sont devant avec avel comme des
lapins je crois que construisent un bel
avenir
je crois que sacrée opération vraiment
on a collé jets de canon qui est
précurseur là dedans ils sont tout
azimut c'est un collège assez
extraordinaire
c'était 18 et je crois que c'est
vraiment que ça que qu'on a recherché et
qui était beau c'est que moi j'ai eu des
difficultés parce que j'ai eu des petits
soucis à la fin du parcours on va dire
avec un petit virus et il ya des élèves
qui m'a dit madame on va porter votre
sac alors que ça faisait huit jours 7
jours que je portais deux sacs
on avait tous les deux je pense ouais 25
kilos sur le dos et donc c'était
chouette de voir que finalement ce n'est
pas parce qu'on est les profs et les
responsables quand on est plus fort et
qu'on voit là c'était vraiment un groupe
quand on s'est soudé à partir du 4e jour
face à la difficulté et c'est ça a été
c'était bon ça a été ça a été vraiment
chouette fois